so it truly saddens me that it's come to
this but at this point dr. deborah birx
one of the doctors that frequently
participates in trumps coronavirus press
briefings we probably can't trust her
anymore she's become sadly a political
tool for Trump repeating absolutely
unbelievable praise about Trump that
none of us would believe for even a
fraction of a second instead of just
telling things like they are dr. Burks
was recently interviewed by the
Christian Broadcasting Network a
disgusting right-wing media outlet she
seemed to have been lobotomized to to to
pick a slightly hyperbolic term compared
to how she used to talk about what we're
dealing with
check this out dr. deborah birx response
coordinator for the White House
coronavirus task force long history of
working productively in infectious
disease immunology she was Obama's
global aids coordinator but slowly but
surely during this coronavirus situation
more and more just deferring to trump
pretending like trump is some kind of
genius with this stuff check out this
clip from her CBN interview she says
Trump is amazing he's just he's
analyzing data
he's integrating that data to make the
best decisions about coronavirus guys
Trump two days ago said he didn't know
whether it was a flu a germ or a virus
Trump admitted yesterday that he learned
a worst-case mortality estimate was 2.2
million deaths yesterday Trump learned
that yesterday okay here is dr. Burks
functioning almost like she's had a
piece of her brain removed how would you
describe the job president Trump is
doing behind the scenes and in front of
the cameras during these daily briefings
that we're seeing what's been your
perspective dr. Burks
he's been so attentive to the scientific
literature and the details and the data
and I think his his ability to analyze
and integrate data that comes out of his
long history in business has really been
a real benefit during these discussions
about medical issues attentive to data
can you imagine
Trump's presidential daily briefings
were reduced from a binder of reports to
one page to one page with just a few
bullet points and a couple of
Trump can't pay attention to anything he
has the attention span of a fruit fly
and dr. Burks says thanks to Trump's
attentiveness to data he's really taking
the data into consideration here's more
of her interview because in the end data
is data and he understands the
importance of the granularity and I
think he's been really excited about
finding the level of detail that we've
been able to now bring over the last few
weeks to really understand who's at the
greatest risk for severe illness who
will have mild unless an asymptomatic
disease and really calling on every
American to do that social distancing
because some people may not know they're
actually infected and be unknowingly
spreading the virus and that all comes
from the president's seeing the data and
then really directing these policies in
these guidelines that go out to the
American people Trump understands the
importance of the granularity and
finding a level of detail what who is
she describing it's not even plausibly
believable that this is the Trump that
this this is how Trump is managing this
the guy learned two days ago about
mortality models that we've had for
weeks and weeks so for me this instantly
raises major questions about dr. Burks
is trustworthy and as we know Trump
doesn't read ever Trump doesn't read
never mind being attentive to the data
it's just it's truly incredible garbage
it's very clear what's going on she
wants to stay on Trump's good side she
has learned the only way to do that is
to praise Donald Trump he's incompetent
he's clueless
he's an existential threat to the
country but dr. Burks has been fully
sucked in so we've got dr. Anthony Fauci
now that's the guy we've had we have
left he clearly is also being very
careful not to get Donald Trump mad at
him
the thing about foul Chi is in
interviews where Trump isn't standing
next to him he's a little bit more of a
truth teller and here was another
non-answer from dr. Burks when when when
the question was asked you know you've
been promising X number of tests some
huge number you've been promising this
huge number of
for weeks and they're not there here is
how dr. Burks answered with one of these
complete non-answer talking point comas
we're learning I know you know last week
and bringing the private sector I think
what has been exciting to me over the
last two and a half weeks is to see this
administration harness the full capacity
of the private sector understanding that
a lot of our solutions that we need to
confront this virus a lot rely on the
private sector bringing the private
sector commercial labs was critical into
this process we are now beginning to see
that they have spread out in a
prioritized way because we ask them to
prioritize the regions that were mostly
affected and so you still may have
difficulty getting tests in areas that
do not have significant cases it really
makes me sad to say it but we just can't
really trust dr. Burks anymore to be
giving us the unvarnished medical and
scientific truth she's giving us
political statements calculated not to
upset Donald Trump we need doctors just
telling us the truth not political
people trying to avoid upsetting Donald
Trump